alors que les refuges temporaires pour
itinérants qui ont été ouverts pendant
le confinement ont fermé les uns après
les autres la situation des personnes
itinérantes est loin d'être réglée les
résidents montréal ont remarqué que
l'espèce de corman a poussé tout près de
la rue notre dame est depuis les
dernières semaines et à vancouver au
moins trois sites et envoyer les images
de vancouver 3 cités tentes ont été
érigées puis démantelé dans des parcs de
la ville
évidemment c'est pas des lieux qui sont
faits pour ça et qui sont pas faits pour
avoir des tendres ya pas de réseau
sanitaire ou quoi que ce soit et on
pense que c'est la pandémie qui a poussé
ces gens là m'ont invité par an par les
samoa thil et le président de la mission
bon accueil mais sur wat bonsoir alors
expliquez nous ce campement on l'appelle
encore maintenant je sais pas comment
vous l'appelez mais ses 7 ans qui ont
été érigées est ce que c'est en effet
des gens qui ont été poussés là par la
pandémie python potes qui sont à bout de
ressources qui trouve pas de ressources
pour une oui il faut être conscient de
la réalité que avec le 26 nov
il ya eu un déplacement dans la
communauté des personnes en situation
différence c'est qu'eux mêmes avaient la
réalité qu'on a réagi rapidement
ensemble faut dire que c'est un travail
d'équipé
il ya la réalité qu' on est on est on
est rendu plus dans la deuxième phase 2
de covile et avec ça il ya des
injustices mans puis aussi des
apprentissages et la réalité c'est qu'il
ya des gens qui ont été déplacés et il
ya on essaie de trouver des solutions
pour ces gens parce que je pense pas que
les gens vraiment veulent faire du
camping nous monsieur watts on se
rappelle j'ai passé rejeté l'ouverture
de l'aréna maurice-richard je pense
était l'hôpital royal vécu en
accueillait des gens justement ce
printemps quand il est un peu plus froid
tout ça mais ça ça a fermé puis ça a
poussé ces gens là à à l'extérieur des
ressources et ça comprend mais en même
temps il ya d'autres sources qui se sont
ouverts qui sont devenues disponibles eu
au cours de la pandémie
ça c'est important parce qu'on
travailler très fort avec le cias
centre-sud avec la ville de montréal
avec d autres ressources commission
borie maison du père et autres au bâtir
ses ressources mais maintenant dans la
deuxième phase il ya un réalité ou sert
sens quand l'aréna maurice richard est
pas disponible mais qu'on fait des
ajustements et l'important c'est qu'on
est capable vraiment de rencontrer ces
gens de parler avec ces personnes parce
que la phénomène d'itinérance c'est un
phénomène complexe il n'y a pas une
solution pour tout le monde
il ya différentes expériences selon les
du mais alors on fait quoi avec ce
campement bij je dis pas qu'il faut le
démanteler là mais il faut venir en aide
à ces gens là c'est ce qu'on comprend
faux faux mais est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on
le laisse leur campement est ce qu'on
est ce qu'on le laisse grossier aussi
avec les contraintes que ça peut
provoquer ou les problèmes que ça peut
provoquer notamment en terme sanitaire
qu'est ce qu'on fait
je pense que la solution vraiment à
moyen terme c'est le logement parce que
les personnes qui sont en situation
d'itinérance au besoin d'un logement
permanent et pour des endroits comme ça
je pense déjà aidé par ailleurs d'un bus
qui sont sur place qui sont en train
d'essayer de bâtir des liens de
confiance avec les personnes en question
heureusement au parc d'une centaine de
personnes c'est 12 ou 20 personnes
alors il ya des possibilités vraiment
comme j'ai dit bâtir des liens de
confiance puis de trouver des solutions
et les solutions seront différents selon
les bidules vous savez quoi calgary il
ya un article sur le site du canada
calgary veut profiter de pandémie pour
mettre fin à l'itinérance est acheté
près de 5000 logements abordables au
cours des prochaines années pour loger
des gens qui sont dans cette situation
là quand vous dites la clé c'est le
logement comme on vous accueille quand
vous soumettez ça aux différents paliers
de gouvernement et qui sont réceptifs à
ce qu'ils sont allés côte comme on vous
accueille c'est important de souligner
que oui ils sont à l'écouté
le projet qui va dérouler bientôt
l'ancien hôpital royal bic c'est un
projet innovateur que nous avons établi
avec la mission au bruit depuis le ciel
centre sud l'idée revient de ça c'est
pas une unité de débordements c'est plus
un endroit de triage d'évaluation et de
référencement
parce que ce qu'on veut faire avec je
dire l'opportunité de proville c de
logis des personnes parce que ces
personnes ont besoin de logements qui
nous autres on est taxé on est passionné
autour du principe de logement des
personnes qui tombent en situation
d'errance devrait pas rester en aide à
ces situations là franchement en 2020 on
devrait être capable à montréal de
trouver du logement contre n'est pas
parlez nous de royal victoria ça va être
un endroit ils vont pouvoir aller dormir
c'est ça et vous devons pouvoir dormir
mr 24 sept
alors nous allons avoir des intervenants
des travailleurs sociaux qui vont être
sur place pour évaluer puis aussi des
agents de logement parce qu'un
autochtone est quelque chose qui apaise
lior s'appelle rejet logement montréal
puis on travaille ensemble en
concertation avec la ville sur sambre se
mission bruit maison du père et autres
il ya des gens peuvent les référés vers
des logements de sont disponibles soit
exactement c'est ça le principe puis
comme j'ai dit tantôt les personnes en
situation d'urgence ont pas besoin des
tentes ils ont besoin du logement
permanent c'est là dessus qu'on se
quitter sur cette réflexion monsieur
watts merci beaucoup et bonne soirée à
vous merci